hey guys you know in this day and age
that we live in Christian men need to
stand on God's word and believe in it
trust in it more than anything else we
need men who live by God confidence and
not selfconfidence we are in a spiritual
battle every day and you cannot let up
for even a second you need to put on the
armor of God and fight with truth
against all the love that is out there
in the world all the distractions and
you need to run your race until the end
to receive the crown of life but how can
you fight if you don't know the truth
God's word do you know his word do you
read it do you study it do you live it
do you use it as part of the armor of
God to fight back against the devil